[Music]
foreign
show starts by making me immediately
steer directly into the sun animated or
not I started watching this with all the
lights off in the room and now I need
new retinas superhuman evasion training
I'm supposed to learn to tuck and roll
away from a guy who can shoot legacies
from his eyes or control minds or kick a
goddamn school bus to the Moon in an
alternate reality where White House
guards need to be prepared to deal with
superhuman combatants the simple concept
of closing the gate between Vehicles
seems to have gotten past these two
along with anyone who has a fake ID or a
Dunkin Donuts perks card for that matter
you're gonna be gone the whole time all
freaking week two all of Matt's spring
break who gets two weeks of spring break
and if there's a school that does I hate
you and I'll send you anyways the boy is
obsessed with the Beatles being obsessed
with the Beatles anytime after 1991. he
stared down his demons and he
foreign
why don't I just make some hot cocoa to
cheer up my sweet boy this is supposed
to be condescending but hot cocoa is
delicious and Steve doesn't make him
follow through with this promise we were
supposed to be inside I should have
never trusted the flood calculations of
a clone clone shaming also this Smurfs
reboot went a little too gritty for my
taste refreshing kind of tickles and
it's wasteful they've been pelting them
with Zero Effect for 30 seconds now so
why keep going your tax dollars at work
am I right
this John Ham Cameo has been right there
watching how bullets don't hurt them and
he still takes a shot kind of feel he
deserves whatever comes his way at this
point
[Music]
I would give this a sin for war women
and the immortal both doing three-point
Landings but Martian Man essentially
does a one point Landing so I'll take
one back so that's the two and then you
subtract the one and then you know what
forget it I hate math just Addison cool
we've got Fish Guy stretchy Groot
discounts Wonder Woman Batman Wolverine
and Flash and chroma key set intern also
superhero posing instead of immediately
getting to work did you come here to
fight or audition for legendary I
wouldn't normally move so fast but
hiring Michael cuddlets to do a Russian
accent and I love Michael cutlets but
based on the fact that Steven young
Lauren Cohan Lenny James Chad L Coleman
and Shaniqua Martin green are also in
the show feels like there was a Walking
Dead cast quota that had to be met
Mahler twin thinks punching through this
wall would be easier than punching
through this window right around the
corner
you're welcome sassing those who are no
longer present we can take
it easy for you throwing someone
straight up into the air is not the same
as getting them to safety this is pretty
much like getting thrown out of a
12-story window because the building is
on fire sure omniman catches them but
nowhere was this scheme agreed upon
prior to the immortal tossing them like
clay targets at a skeet shooting range
I had him but I wanted him to think he
was going to fall to his death because
that's how I have fun evacuation
complete now we can cut loose and focus
on taking these brutes down according to
my interpretation of Heart of Darkness
by Joseph Conrad the Guardians of the
globe may just as well fall into the
category of fruits with the smaller
twins I purport that war women's
evocation of the Guardians will in this
instance fall short of addressing the
underlying moral and ethical questions
one must ask regarding the use of
superhuman force in the battle against
the ever present and would-be forces of
evil also she said evacuation this
Teamwork Makes the DreamWorks segment of
the Guardians of the globe handling the
steroid enhanced Blue Man Group might be
inspiring but it makes no sense first
green ghost drops them into pavement
they've already shown they're stronger
than at which point Martian Bland Hunter
wraps them up for containment so flash
Borden can land a few non-effective
punches then they let him go why
apparently so fish dude can free them
and also maybe soak them with water at
which point Bruce plain can drop a
couple bombs on them and Shira can
poolhost them on top of each other which
I I guess ends the battle this is such a
stupid gameplay and I'm giving the show
15 sins just for insulting our
intelligence I used to change your
diapers kid there's nothing going on
down there I haven't seen before be
often overused I'm your mom and I've
seen your genitals cliche that being
said she's not nearly concerned enough
that her son's reading something called
Seance dog if my mom caught me reading
Seance anything that would definitely be
grounds for a discussion at least and
yes I know the science dog reference but
your reference doesn't outweigh my
sheltered childhood damn it you should
be overjoyed to see your parents
passionately expressing their love for
each other no he shouldn't and nor
should he have to I don't know the story
behind why the high school is called
Reginald Vil Johnson and I don't care I
just know it's awesome Long Live Carl I
can't believe the Guardians of the globe
let them get that close to killing the
President William would be Invincible at
TV since what kind of schedule is this
Mark has three free periods every day
and apparently no classes on Friday even
in this reality the school system sucks
you're such an omni Maniac way to root
for the underground dog big fan of the
Yankees are you William thinks a
superhero with a high success rate isn't
cool I don't even watch baseball but if
every time the Yankees won a game it
prevented the catastrophic loss of life
I'd probably root for them as well quit
playing games I know you're crazy about
me vanity no man has ever run away this
fast after being kicked in the balls oh
you want to run away but nature dictates
that you must cower in the fetal
position for a while first millions of
miles from here out in deep space
is the planet viltrum expositional
fathering Exposition that's when I Met
Your Mother the dialogue suggests that
this scene is depicting Omni man saving
Debbie but it looks more like he's
threatening to drop a car on her also
shows should get credit for not making
us wait over 200 episodes to meet the
mother just to have her die 30 minutes
later but you made me think of all that
[ __ ] so I'm gonna send you anyways
Canada t-shirts that say Canada on them
instead of how do you like my t-shirt
jehosher he is not getting hold of
superpower because Mark is flying
shirtless in shoeless this far up in the
atmosphere and well his nipple should be
at attention and ready to cut some
glasses all I'm saying
I do
no one hears this or even mentions the
damage the next day you're much better
off if you relax that muscle from time
to time use the momentum You're Building
to carry you forward these flying
lessons go on for all the sometime could
this have just been a montage with a
Survivor song playing over it you know
you spend your whole life trying not to
pee your pants so Letting Go peeing your
pants on purpose it's next to Impossible
it is not or I mean so I've heard are
you questioning me it seems like a
pretty aggressive turn for Romney man to
go from loving to abusive in like 20
minutes but foreshadowing has to
foreshadow I guess
foreign
Titan's superpower appears to be an
easily defeated candy coating can't
blame a guy for trying to move unsold
merchandise true but you can't call
[ __ ] on this guy having an already
tailored suit that fits Mark perfectly
sorry about the yard how does no one in
this neighborhood know that the Grayson
house has superheroes omniman just takes
off from the roof at any given time and
Mark makes human-sized gopher holes in
the backyard I love my boring powerless
everyday run-of-the-mill mom and I love
my [ __ ] son the Mother's Day
conversation I had with my mom somehow
makes it into this episode even if this
ball could have found the perfect
momentum to not Escape orbit and somehow
avoid any High terrain at this speed it
would have completely disintegrated from
the friction also this is an incredibly
negligent game of catch everything else
aside from the fact that omniman is
encouraging this makes his turn to
villainy not so surprising you actually
are
Invincible roll commercials or since I
guess this is streaming roll next thing
the algorithm picks for you so you can't
escape the sweet sweet Embrace of
never-ending content flows right off the
tongue huh rolling the credits here is
confusing there's like a whole 10
minutes left so is this a 37 minute long
cold open or a 10 minute mid-credit
scene either way I'm excited to see what
the next 10 minutes hold so I can finish
this thing off with all the good
feelings completely intact
show never explains why a villain who
thinks a biplane would provide the best
thrust or weight ratio for a jet pack
has such a serious Vendetta against
Denver
um man take me with you kids no Nikki
Nikki you know guardian's business is
too dangerous for human children it's
also dangerous to leave children hanging
around abandoned buildings like this one
the screen ghost keep that pill in her
pocket that seems like an item that is
too important for a pocket designation
he may be the hero this city deserves
but he's not the mallard we want right
now
this mountain looks remarkably similar
to the one Invincible through the
baseball through a little too similar
while this interesting turn of events is
pretty cool and I love this shot of red
Rush fighting so hard he breaks his own
hands while punching omniman this all
occurs in the last five minutes the rest
of this episode was pretty by the book
but not in a way that made these
characters endearing enough for me to
even lament their loss also this last
five minutes has more dismemberment than
an entire saw film might have to watch
spiral after this for a palette cleanser
why
why because modern television is
addicted to Cliffhangers that's why Joe
contains a very important warning for
anyone with photosensitivity but forgets
to include an additional warning about
eating food while watching the show and
I'm still bitter about my baked potato
turning sour in my mouth during the
final minutes of episode one show
informs us that the queen is not in
Residence but never explores this
further what a tease it's not about
rooms
it's about power
that building has one purpose to say I'm
the queen and you are my subjects but it
also says I'm the queen and need my
staff available so I'm going to make
sure everyone's close and doesn't need
to drive to work but that doesn't sound
quite as dramatic oh no is that blood
yeah just wants trick us into thinking
that this is a continuation of the
bloodbath we saw in the last episode but
instead it's just trash from the burger
Mart and we all know that fast food
garbage is comprised of 25 meat 25 food
containers and 50 ketchup tampering with
evidence
clear no you're solid now you were clear
a second ago silly the animators decided
that if they were gonna go through with
all the trouble to draw a dismembered
body that it needed to be shown at least
64 times we get it they died
horrifically sure spray acquires his
corpse down with lube and attach the
doodad to make us think Immortal might
survive toy with my emotions and
momentarily trick me into thinking the
Guardians could be saved I could handle
it
don't bump her she is dead sir her head
has been relocated on its axis bumper
all you want she doesn't give a [ __ ]
about bumps leaving a book on a stove
top this coffee maker is running way too
hot for a traditional drip machine
either there's a wiring problem or I'm
the man is being a dick to Debbie's
tongue 50 of the shower's useless space
as the global Defense Agency we have
access to Medical Technology far beyond
any normal hospital Exposition Ah that's
one of our threat response teams we're
not in the mood for the tour Donald oh
thank you Debbie this big ass screen is
needed to monitor blood pressure and
temperature with just a little bit of
attention to design economy they could
eliminate most of these other screens I
would probably cut the power usage of
this room in half we're a little
understaffed in the hero Department
category is things that should have been
said quietly but needed to be spoken
loud enough for someone else to hear and
move the story along give
Invincible brings these half-assed
verbal commands to a firefight that is
already in progress
oh my God once you suffer a dislocated
fracture you never get used to seeing
that and since I'm in the driver's seat
I'm sitting that I don't know who you
are but it's time to go well now that a
superhero set a one-liner of sorts the
winning can start
you also redirected weapons fire from
the civilians on the street to the ones
in the building so really it's all about
perspective
okay none of these people are paying
attention to where they are walking but
these guys act like Mark is the ass for
not yielding to them these guys you and
Debbie need a lasagna I make a good one
calling your friend's mom by her first
name rather than Mrs Grayson also
everyone thinks that their lasagna is
the best but everyone is always wrong
about their lasagna true lasagna has no
ricotta cheese hi Mom
God that sounds dumb when I say it like
that sounds a little optimistic maybe
mark would be excellent at TV since but
you've knocked that one out of the park
I'm Adam Eve you don't say you are the
superhero that looks exactly like a girl
named Eve with hair and eyes the exact
same you don't say You're the Reason
Todd beat him up again oh yes blame her
for existing I never recognized you
before no one does it's a psychology
thing if you don't expect to see a
Superhero in your school you don't see a
Superhero in your school I agree with
this every time I think I see a
celebrity on the street I do a double
take stare for a minute realize I've
been staring too long and have to
pretend like I'm looking at birds or
some and even after that I'm unsure if I
just saw a celebrity or not however I
don't think this applies to super
powered individuals who use their
abilities as indiscreetly as Adam even
Invincible do whether or not expect to
see a person fly away I will definitely
notice that when it happens that's us
everyone's fourth favorite superhero
team wait what the number of superheroes
on this show seems to be increasing
exponentially if there are that many
superhero teams I would start thinking
it's very likely to see a Superhero at
your school now I have to retcon these
sins that's much better you'll get used
to it the fights not the barfing so to
be clear barfing is the thing that
people will never get used to where's
the fighting dismemberment murder chaos
and death of Innocents and baddies alike
will seem very normal she's evil I'm
calling it despite all the details that
went into the Articles themselves the
names of these Publications are phoned
in and online news is the worst also not
one of these sources asks for permission
to collect cookies they ran off because
they were dying of old age well I will
have to say I saw this romance coming
from a mile away from one giant show to
another Moko made's twitch motto somehow
makes its way into this episode Damien
dark Blood Demon detective show thinks I
used up all my good Darkwing Duck
material on the first episode but plan a
has and always will be this song three
two one damning dark blood when there's
trouble you call the Double D Damien
dark blood Let's Get Dangerous try to
keep up the most frustrating part of
this training montage is that it
completely avoids explaining how
anyone's hair stays tangle free despite
whipping in the wind without being tied
back no one still get cheap ride with a
soft top down it took me three hours to
come out the tangles and I have a buzz
cut breakfast until 10 43 a.m why not 10
45 why not 10 30. I guess it doesn't
matter because no matter when the cutoff
starts someone will pull up to the
window 10 seconds too late in demand to
have breakfast like an [ __ ]
asking someone to do what they were
already doing Reflections come from a
dimension with a faster temporal rate as
a result the tachyons they emit spin
more rapidly than our own show expects
me not to conflate spinning tachyons
with the spinning DNA on this Monitor
and I simply cannot allow that are you
okay Donald said you saved a lot of
lives yeah it was just um harder than I
thought I'm glad Mrs Grayson is checking
in with her son but wouldn't this have
been a conversation she would have had
earlier while comforting him in the
midst of his blood-covered drama I'm not
gonna send Rex somehow being annoying
during what I assume is his post-coital
celebratory milk drinking but I am going
to send Rex for being one of those
people that drinks straight from the
container so you
you more awesome than him and take his
that's how dating
is not
over excessive pen clicking why aren't
they getting old
in the previous fight it took the alien
several minutes before showing signs of
aging and the Teen team has shown up at
the very beginning of their newest
Invasion be patient kids sheesh teen
team starts the battle with the same
unsuccessful tactics as they did in the
last one duply flip jumps about letting
her copies get massacred sex load throws
his balls at people Zachary quinjet does
his best Iron Man impersonation and
Pinky in the lame makes use of her Swiss
Army Bubble Yum the only significant
difference is that intolerable discovers
the power of boners so they target The
Wristband expertly but what stopped them
from being so precise with their
previous attacks could she not pink
Spike through their brains
Invincible is a dick to health care
workers in the poor bleeding soul that
needed this gauze hey I need my costume
back I don't care how torn up it is it's
classified and I want it back go get it
now these intermittent bouts of unwanted
hostility race questions like maybe
Nolan has a thyroid problem also viltra
might privilege
breathless human has time for this wow I
get it taking the view while you can but
does does Mark not need to breathe
anymore is that part of being Invincible
even on their third attempt these aliens
are still opening their portals across
from each other thereby funneling all
their troops into one easily surrounded
location I'm no military scholar but we
all know it's not fun to keep using the
same predictable positions also the teen
team never once attempts to exploit this
teens rack sleeps from the vehicle here
and can he fly I don't think he can fly
Rex is dead and I demand to see the
animation to confirm this I'm sure he's
explaining nicely why they should leave
us alone show makes me cautiously
rethink some of the things my mama said
to me over the years that I may have
previously misinterpreted to me my
father was not systematically destroying
a civilization the juxtaposition of this
scene against the one where Invincible
fights Allen clearly establishes the
differences between the two characters
not only regard to physical ability but
also in the way of desire and motivation
it's a brilliant bit of Storytelling
done through action sequences and
without Exposition but also genocide I'm
at a loss for how to report this but the
Guardians of the globe are dead
for [ __ ] sake did we need this eyebrow
we already know he killed them the show
just spent two minutes showing us his
ruthlessness just enjoy hugging your
family Nolan again with the sun show
doesn't think it can open an episode
without looking at the sky and that's
the second time this fetish has caused
me eyeball pain writers include this
this and this just in case we confused
it with Japan Missouri and we are left
to wonder
who will save us now
I will vanity everyone has black
umbrellas at a funeral cliche never
[Music]
defying funeral crashing I may have
completely forgotten how to write in
cursive but I know most of these are
just random squiggles shame on you dark
blood pretending to take notes didn't
mean to offend Nuance of human
conversation difficult for me well army
man isn't human so the Nuance is moot
robot you know for a bunch of computer
code
you run a main superhero team are there
no other robots in this world has this
name never been an issue when robot just
happens to be standing next to another
robot or is robot a surname and Cecil is
just one of those people also that's
roboticed this flower over here looks
very similar to this flower over here a
little too similar hey he could run fast
okay it's not exactly one of your
Premier superpowers Nolan is a dick to
speedsters I was thinking finals are
coming up and we're both in Miss
Walker's Global issues class study dates
while I do believe these books do
contain references to bio and math I
find it hard to accept that any
publisher worth their salt would use
titles this General I knew there was a
reason you skipped the funeral skipping
a funeral to have sex with duplicate
wait is that actually a sin hold on
what's that
okay so I was just informed that this is
a 100 without a doubt no questions asked
a sin sure I actually think this joke is
pretty hilarious but geometry despite
your name I believe you underestimate
yourself Invincible but Mark said
nothing about doubting himself he said
he couldn't join because his dad wanted
to handle training him and his mom
didn't want him to miss any more school
and then the director said have him
bounce his pecs that will make him look
like even more of an apple wait what
somebody audited you some [ __ ]
despite being surrounded by super
powered individuals Rex chode
underestimate someone named monster girl
come on man read the room also Rex
survives this we find out monster girl
is wary of transforming often since
every time she does she gets a little
younger so why is she wasting a change
on [ __ ] Rex load Invincible hit that
little girl show thinks that someone who
just witnessed that fight between Rex
and monster girl is really going to try
and cancel Invincible over this I'm sure
your junk is awesome even with the power
Dynamic reversed this still feels wrong
welcome to the Guardians of the globe
monster girl along with Rex blood what
exactly is Rex splod bringing to the
table you're telling me that out of the
20 or so superheroes that didn't make it
none of them were more qualified than
Rex because I do not believe you
cheated on me with duplicate all three
of her
whoa Envy whoa and now lust this show is
full of a lot of actual sins so I'm sure
no one will complain about our video
this time around
as soon as the forensic investigation
has concluded we'll be moving into the
guardian's headquarters not a single one
of these numb skulls thinks it might be
a bad idea to set up shop at the scene
of the former guardian's unsolved murder
it's like they say die a hero or live
long enough to see yourself become an
Eco villain
[Music]
putting aside the little detail of the
stairs leading directly to the front
door why is this even necessary unless
Amber for some reason hates dating guys
with friends William's presence should
have absolutely no impact on her
perception of Mark well then the whole
concept of personal privacy or me time
that's out the window Facebook's user
agreement doc seismic isn't burned
seared or lightly browned in any way
despite being Incredibly Close to Lava
also there is no Lava close to the
surface of Mount Rushmore Invincible
completes this repair without a proper
mortar mix he doesn't even consider a
bonding agent that's just shoddy
craftsmanship those aren't close gloves
of fingers they're more uh earthquake
bracelets all these are essentially
bracelets Invincible doesn't acknowledge
the existence of fingerless gloves also
mocking this dangerous technology that
has probably already killed several
people also also taking time for these
not so clever quips when the success of
your date depends upon you dealing with
this situation quickly and efficiently I
thought your doctor was in seismology
undergrad in sociology and women's
studies I had a minor in African dance
holy woke villain Darkwing I mean I
don't know if I should [ __ ] him or fight
him random tourists randomly being put
into random Jeopardy are random show
creates false tension by expecting us to
believe that this man will die a
horrible death Joe also assumes I will
care if this man dies a horrible death
and I do not wow that guy is toast oh I
see so like none of these sound good huh
punch shaming you left a girl in your
room while you flew off to deal with a
crisis good yeah because telling Amber
you forgot you had something to do and
you can meet up later so then she could
go back home or wherever and accomplish
other things and possibly hold on to
some dignity would just be silly one
last piece of fatherly advice okay
you might want to change Asha do Nolan
I'm assuming both Mark and Debbie would
have people that don't know Nolan is
Omni man over to the house so why would
he ever be just wandering around the
downstairs with his Omni man showing I
sold a house today that had a double
homicide I told him lightning never
strikes twice technically it did strike
twice just in Rapid succession Thursday
chicken pot pie kidding this excited
about chicken pot pie go ahead wrote me
in with his Cliffhanger reveal that
robot was actually behind the Mahler
twin Escape because otherwise I had no
intention whatsoever to watch any more
episodes of this very entertaining take
on the superhero genre Escape From Hell
seek Justice for others to save old and
soul show knows exactly what it feels
like to quit your job in sales blow all
your money on developing a terrible
student film and ultimately end up
writing for TV since maybe too soon in
the series to make this call but I don't
care Nolan furrows his brow cliche the
skip recap button that's right I'm
sending the Amazon interface for
allowing me to skip a part of the show
that I previously sinned sure it looks
all sexy and convenient but it offloads
the administration of this experience
onto me this is essentially the digital
equivalent of the self-checkout Lane at
the supermarket stop trying to automate
perfectly good jobs plus my hands are
currently occupied with stuffing
artificially flavored cheesy popcorn
into my face and I'll not risk the
sanctity and cleanliness of my remote by
handling it while my hands are covered
in what feels like a mixture of Elmer's
glue and climbing chalk do we have to
see the Immortals decapitation every
damn time and why am I still trying to
eat Taco Bell while watching this show I
might have a problem Joe has Bryant
Mumble step on this scorpion throw a
cigarette at this guy and push past this
crowd instead of just giving him an
apple to prove how much of an [ __ ] he
is now I have to give this three sins
instead of one also murder discount Jon
Hamm only one snap and no shake that's
just blatant disregard to the
established glow stick activation
procedure there is no way it would be
this luminous
what the discounts that ippo think
discount Indiana Jones was up to nothing
good comes from opening mummy tombs
there's an insane amount of examples in
other shows and movies you could have
done some [ __ ] researches all I'm
saying
my first thought was that this door fell
into place by sheer luck my second
thought was that one of these guys just
happened to be proactive enough to shut
the door on this nightmare my third
thought was that omniman threw this door
into place as he and Invincible were
flying by finally my forethought was
giving this moment a sin because I'm
pretty sure five thoughts would have
caused a Nexus event and frankly I don't
have time for that messing up the desert
huh
JK Simmons man JK [ __ ] Simmons what
happened to name some altitude messing
up the desert closer to the surface now
than Invincible was when he was kicking
up the sandstorms wait where's Mount
Everest it's the high one dad directions
take deep breaths buddy the Air's been
up here Show's already established that
invincible's lungs are too strong for
this to make any sense in episode 2 he
held his breath during a lengthy flight
in space then a conversation in space
and then took time to stop and enjoy the
view from space why would breathing be a
concern here sometimes I forget how
beautiful this planet can be too bad the
human race is hell bent on destroying it
like if I want a Captain Planet I'd
watch will Captain Planet this login
screen has no forgot password link
considering how much effort went into
writing these articles in episode two I
was really surprised that the show went
with this lorem ipsum nonsense but
judging by the glowing Circle forming in
my living room
reading that Latin text aloud may have
been a bad choice I'll deal with that
later
Amber Mark appear to be traveling in the
same direction despite the fact that
Mark's legs are clearly angled at least
45 degrees to the direction of travel
they're called balls throwing a hard B
on your balls slow hanging fruit maybe
you came to finish the job you started
with the Guardians you're the demon
after all that's demonist if you
threaten my family again cliche
run the jewels or not soundtracking my
daily activities in this scene this very
sophisticated device used to make clones
runs on frozen hamburgers we're cool
right don't know don't care skip
alienating Adam Eve was the direct
result of your lapse in judgment do not
repeat it with monster girl since the
show's been pretty well written so far
I'll presume this whole scene as a setup
for something that being said this is
gross and even though Rex even explains
why it's gross what are you crazy man
she looks like she's 14. that doesn't
make the choice to put it in the show
any less gross now that I'm a guardian I
can bang anyone I wall using your
position in the corporate ladder to gain
sexual advantages I like dealing with
work stuff yeah and I love that about
you don't give me that marriage Mark is
not trying at all to conceal that secret
identity which makes this conversation
later with Eve about telling Amber who
he is all the more odd what a favorite
forgotten to tell Mark something or open
the door right here or a neighbor was
out walking their dog I don't like Mark
missing school this is Debbie's worry
that Mark will miss school not that
he'll be going to a planet humans and
never set foot on or that he'll be in
space for the next two weeks or just
about anything could happen but yeah
missing an English exam real bummer sure
but it's not like dating Rex worked out
Mark survives this you help me with my
Amber stuff I'll help you with your Rec
stuff how exactly would Mark help Eve
with her Rex stuff can you go back in
time and stop Rex from being a cheating
[ __ ] I don't think he can I figured
you'd need something that's a nice
gesture for Mark but where did he get
the 800 that turned him off from buying
the ball in the first place I'm I'm
going away and helping people this works
first off just look how [ __ ] cool
this space shuttle is second look at how
aerodynamically unsound these rocket
boosters are I may not have the time or
education to properly calculate drag
coefficients but I assume rectangular
cuboids have either lots of drags or
lots of coefficients unless something
goes wrong I'm a ghost even as a ghost
the people inside can probably hear you
tap dancing across the outside of their
ship there are
so would be Invincible at TV sins
martians way to bury the lead Cecil
actually the lead is make sure our
astronauts get home safe take
technically Cecil still buried the lead
he didn't mention this till after the
Martian talk I know you're all tired of
me preaching about Kessler syndrome but
when you're done playing with your
villains you can't just leave them
floating in orbit it's a disaster
waiting to happen as I noted earlier
Mark has already been to space once but
didn't take note of the temperature or
think that maybe sandwiches don't work
in the vacuum of space they land the
ship for a second and hop straight the
[ __ ] out this is Mars not a rest stop
don't you have to check with Fido first
or some [ __ ] this extra is staring right
at the camera
considering the convenience of this
Dragon popping up literally right behind
them while they're in another country if
I were Debbie I'd be thinking Nolan set
these Shenanigans up so the answer is no
Debbie it's [ __ ] no I don't trust you
Nolan
I guess the good thing for dark blood is
no one will ever ask him to be on plant
watering duty while they're out of town
other humans in white are they like you
aliens conveniently speak English cliche
alone the group mind is scattered and
weak but with an appropriate host they
become unified and Unstoppable Snyder
Bros how exactly is Mark protecting the
astronauts he's giving them zero cover
he should at least be running behind
them
early Invincible doesn't even need his
key to open this door which is
surprising when you consider how
paranoid Nolan was when Cecil showed up
earlier but more importantly Nolan and
Debbie deserve a sin for going to pound
town with the front door unlocked when
you know you have a teenage son who just
come home at any moment but more
importantly the last time we saw these
two Nolan pretty much refused to save
people from a fire-breathing dragon and
apparently Debbie was super turned on by
this this is a sin because I used to
like you Debbie see that's the problem
with demons you only see good and evil
black and white no the problem with
demons is they never pick up their toys
oh wait that's kids same difference
finally phase one begins but what the
[ __ ] happened to The Mummy from the
beginning of the episode slow zoom into
a waking cityscape the streets are ready
for action I've got a good feeling this
is gonna be a really awesome episode of
Law and Order
was that a yawn usually ion after I see
someone else do it but this is a
half-assed attempt to make me feel the
weight of this man's work day maybe this
is foreshadowing how I may feel after
sending this episode wearing sunglasses
at night while smoking a cigarette in a
tank top so you can show you you can
look like even more of an [ __ ] from
the 80s neither one of these guys pulls
the gun up and out in any perceivable
way so as far as I can tell they've
pulled the gun sideways through the seam
of their pants I do not expect this
trend to catch on
[Applause]
consciously courteous concrete criminal
is a casual coffee cup conservationist
in a world of super powered beings you
choose to observe the shadowy cafe
Crusader instead of shooting him on site
before he goes rock hard for your base
he didn't even bring you a coffee after
stopping to get himself one that's
enough Merit to blow away this discount
Dwayne The Rock Johnson concreting your
head last instead of first this guy's
not killed instantly after being hit
with a forklift instead he and it's get
across the ground and are pinned up
against some racks that should have also
been killed in this event I'm guessing
the forklift was paying more attention
in its drama class than in physics
bringing in the big guns huh you sure
about that Titan's been beating humans
with other humans and you think bringing
a bigger pew pew will do the job size in
this case doesn't matter Titan's lack of
resourcefulness is playing a big part in
time spent dealing with these goons he's
been disarming these guys for what seems
like 15 minutes it hasn't picked up a
gun to shoot back at them he could have
had enough time to enjoy a post Beatdown
vanilla bean latte before heading home
if he wasn't taking his superpower for
granite thinking that screaming while
firing your weapon makes it more
effective
[Music]
ah good stab the rock band in the chest
who has been deflecting bullets during
the entire raid what's next eating soup
with a fork yo
why are these buttons on this phone
during playback since when do you need a
record button while you're watching your
footage no matter what circumstances
would I need to select the front-facing
camera I'm just trying to watch my
latest Tick Tock phone leave me alone
you went all the way across town to get
cheesecake yep to make up for being late
because you went across town to get
cheesecake I was initially confused as
to why he didn't have two cheesecakes
and then I realized that Amber and Mark
just choose to communicate in the most
bizarre way possible however now I'm
just upset that I don't have two
cheesecakes so I'm gonna give them three
cents I know his pants aren't on Fires
Beyond me but since he always removes
his shirt I'm a little confused about
the blade and disregard for pants don't
tell me the Rock's being shy about it
stalactite or possibly stalagmite
depending on the situation what did we
ever do to you Kevin my man Titan just
lit your entire apartment complex Ablaze
as you watched I think the better
question is why you didn't immediately
call 9-1-1 when Titan started to commit
arson after eating the cat villain I'm
guessing that invincible's more of a dog
person here I am throwing all my good
boots out trying to silence the cat
coffin of Alley Cats next to my home
when I should be digging out my Superman
Halloween costume from 2012 and chucking
the cats through a wall this show has
made it clear I must dismantle the
invasion of the third meow led by the
fur you've been late 12 times in the
past three months I'm sorry but I'm
docking your shifts does he mean talking
his pay because technically speaking it
sounds like Mark is already docking his
shifts on his own racing
getting Batman in a non-dc property yeah
principal Winslow taking Family Matters
name in vain without going full
crossover episode you're lives worth
minimum wage but do you want to fire
your guns in the air so you tried your
best and we all walk away happy
and alive I can understand the confusion
this cause because even though they're
indoors air is still all around them but
it's still weird the thriders didn't
have at least one of these guards
consider the inevitable investigation
where they're gonna have to explain why
they all shot at the ceiling instead of
the perpetrator you're a walking pile of
rocks that's roxist I know where your
family lives and that means you work for
me until I say you're [ __ ] done this
excessive usage of auto-tune sure when
it's Tastefully done it adds a
futuristic vibe that can supplement your
overall aesthetic but none of that even
rhymed T-Pain is on the phone he wants
you off the mixtape plus now you got to
pay for the desk too this was imported
Italian Maple Nave if you had any
inkling of Exquisite taste in the fine
Fashions of woodworking jadels you'd be
aware that the African Blackwood would
complement this office space better
oh
invincible's ability to breathe the
varying altitudes remains frustratingly
confusing in episode 4 I had to address
the strangeness of him having trouble
breathing on Mount Everest when in
episode 2 he had no trouble holding his
breath for long periods in space and now
in episode 5 I have to address the fact
that he appears to be breathing at all
while hanging out somewhere near the
Carmen line when in episode 4 he was
having trouble breathing on Mount
Everest how does it feel to save the
world why not break the meteor into tiny
pieces with your super strength you said
a meteor hurling into deep space at such
a velocity that it would decimate any
planet in its trajectory for a date with
a girl that doesn't even like your
Diversified cheesecakes I'm not sure
you're earning the Hero part of
superhero
nobody awoke to their house being blown
apart my dog would have lost his hearing
Invincible outside of his home never
mind getting a portion of your garage
Blown Away not to mention the lights are
on so people are awake did somebody ask
for butterscotch Ripple the show's
already spent a considerable amount of
time showing us that Titan isn't all
that bad so much so that the suggestion
of him about to attack a child feels so
out of character that this ice cream
turn isn't the least bit surprising also
pretending that butterscotch is a
child's favorite ice cream flavor
forcing elephants back into captivity he
calls himself
I'll admit this title card's funny every
time but at 15 minutes in it'd be
funnier if you just continued on with
this momentum that the story is created
and by funny or I just mean better
Facebook also artists thought that just
because dark blood was a demon he'd be
committed to the whole evil notebook of
the Dead aesthetic when he was clearly
throwing a more hip moleskin Vibe what
was the name of that place in Bordeaux
the one with the chocolate pastry
thingies show dangles this delicious
sounding pastry thread in front of us
but doesn't follow it a single bit
further leaving notes without context so
when you go back to do further research
you cannot for the life of you remember
why you wrote down cubits amuse-bouche
in Donnie Benet all guys make mistakes
using your man card to justify the
Betrayal of trust I tried using that
statement once when I super glued my
finger and my belly button the outcome
was the same you just look like an idiot
you're an 18 year old girl
you can't do this hero [ __ ] on your
own parents I can rearrange atoms on a
molecular level like it's easy wait I
actually could do his weird pink energy
things I had no idea she could put doors
in weird places where was that during
the interdimensional Alien Invasion also
Conjuring a door mid-wall and without
consent yeah more like a big picture
superhero pretending that you're as
important and relevant as a Marvel or DC
hero you do know you're on Amazon right
letting your pride get in the way of
experiencing flight maybe [ __ ] to
you Titan but somewhere out there is a
kid dreaming of being fairied to the bad
places of the City by their favorite
superhero
with the trash company
uses it to Ferry drugs to stash houses
all over the city using the trash bins
is clever but garbage trucks have to be
the most impractical truck for this job
for one you don't put trash cans inside
them because there's all that compactor
Tech in there and two even if you did
manage to cram one or two trash cans in
there good luck getting them out without
attracting attention to what should be a
covert operation just say a Machine Head
seems like you'd be smarter than this
even though people use it generically
popsicle is a trademarked name you
wouldn't see a Kleenex Palace would you
although it really might be handy to
have one next to the popsicle Palace now
that I think about it I know I can take
Machine Head he's just a criminal with a
special head having a special head is
often a sign of huge problems for a
superhero Modoc Brainiac Juggernaut
doesn't he read comic books putting
mashed potatoes right on top of your
already separated food you fought off an
alien invasion save the country from an
asteroid this is beneath you filter mic
classism that's the last time the lizard
League turns people into snakes in my
town the lizard League Mr opportunity
for the name snake Society or serpent
Squad why did the lizard League choose
to turn people into snakes instead of
lizards sure they're both reptiles but
everyone knows that lizard people are
far superior to snake people it's like
viltermike classes in 101. I'm also
caught up in your own little prize bites
that you let this entire bus of
civilians crash flyer monster girls
fighting but Rex looks like he's taking
a long happy second to observe the menu
of a burger mark down the road or that
he just enjoys hearing the sound of
screeching tires and children on fire as
usual I'll be the only person who
actually sacrificed something since I'm
now a week younger than I was yesterday
kids it's only been a hero for a few
months he thinks he knows everything I
just don't want him to make a choice
he'll regret like sloppy slaughtering an
entire superhero Team without doing much
to cover your painful Barefoot Lego
trail of evidence like that regret you
want to come tonight we could use the
help I wish I could but too busy saving
the world well done Amber you've
accidentally put two and two together
about Eve's superhero career but how are
you still oblivious to Marx he's
becoming more in and out of your life
than my dad has in mind just just don't
let Mark go get milk
hi I'd like to schedule a therapy
appointment I almost forgot how good I
look button press buff Blue Man reveal
technology electricity excitement
three-point Landing cliche Debbie's
calculations show 12 minutes of travel
time while she sets a timer for 20
minutes take a look past this
discrepancy is a possible estimate to
account for wait times at each stop but
there are so many unknown variables here
such as Nolan's flight speeds and just
how long is he willing to wait at these
shops he doesn't seem to be a very
patient man so the fact that the timer
goes off exactly when he gets back makes
this whole scene it conveniently
contrived pile of this works Nolan put
his murder suit on this weird shelf
above the window instead of sinking into
the bottom of the ocean tossing it into
an active volcano or just throwing it
straight into the sun now even on the
off chance he planted it here on purpose
I'm still giving this a sin because
throwing it into the sun wasn't plan a
oh yeah these guys know what's up it
doesn't matter how good you are at
security as much as how cool you look
doing it no way you saw this car I mean
I did not because I'm watching you do it
now Titan but because this build
building was foreshadowed four times in
the industry we call this foreshadowing
it's not quite as wasteful as doing four
score shadowing but still a bit much
which is how I know it's not worth
explaining to you to morons what Quantum
probabilities are well Machine Head Is
Right simply because that would take a
lot of time and it's not like they're
paying for this lecture so you'd only
have an incentive to do this if he was
the type of person that derived value
from sharing his wisdom with others
clearly he is not that being said his
statement about probability evokes an
alarming amount of certainty so much so
that I'm wondering if someone needs to
explain to him what Quantum
probabilities are mixing food with one
hand you look like you're good at
chopping things how'd you know cause
she's a Supra never mind wait invisible
is bloodied when did that happen he gets
covered in lava and electricity and
smashed into a wall and a floor then
uppercut by Big the cat with a mace and
then this this is where you want to show
damage on him it's almost like you want
him to be impervious until the plot
needs him to bleed whatever the case the
show's name from this point should now
be occasionally vincible
foreign
not reading the room
not reading your texts
wait I'm getting something here what
not using the already blown out door for
maximum property damage see you got an
anonymous call Samson feels the need to
deliver this information which is pretty
much like the paramedic showing up to
your car crash finding you bleeding out
and pausing to explain that someone
called them and that not happened they
wouldn't be there
please [ __ ] Taco Bell's new slogan
somehow makes it into the episode not to
tell Machine Head how to spend his own
money but he could have just had isotope
teleport battle Beast here instead of
wasting his money on the rest of these
goons take it from Confucius Machine
Head he who will not economize will have
to agonize this fight was so good I'm
not even gonna call it a discount Thanos
versus Hulk in fact this fight is so
good Marvel should take notes this fight
is so good I'm taking a sin away and
adding it to the next Marvel show in
spite I'm gonna make the city better for
a lot of people
some people come first
inviting your family to a bloodied
battle-ridden office doesn't seem like
the best parental choice to preserve
child innocence just look up honey just
look up having the secret lab be
accessible from the main elevator not
only creates opportunities for these
awkward interactions it also increases
the likelihood that an individual like
myself could hack their way into the lab
not with skill but with immature button
mashing I'm like an expert button Masher
watch
uh oh
oh
um City
can you fix that
[Music]
thanks I need my costume back and I want
it back am I important to you I'm gonna
do better I'm not even sure I want to do
this anymore clone I need your expertise
I'm here for you I thought mark would be
here tonight every one of these [ __ ]
in the previously on being all me me me
me me maybe if you didn't lose your
powers except Rex
man battle Beast using three types of
paint colors for your investigation when
one black pen and colored highlighters
are an option also the red ink is under
the Black Ink meaning the circles came
before the word blood which is just a
dumb way to take notes this uninspired
yet framed original artwork what's
important going for Rick Sanchez you
never go full Rick Sanchez you're going
to be in what started out as a cute
title card gag has now morphed into an
anxiety-inducing slap bet even in the
real world my heart rate increases every
time someone says keep an eye on that
plane and I keep an eye on a gushing
wound how about pressure how about
giving pressure there you go find out
what kind of blood she can take show
wants me to believe that with all the
preparation Cecil's making for an
eventual Showdown with omniman that he's
completely overlooked the medical needs
of the security Guardians of the globe
how are they even operating on him right
now even if they have some sort of
special viltermite surgical tools this
does raise the question is he or is he
not thank God whatever tore him up is
sharp I'm sure the reason for this
statement has something to do with
making it harder to put all the bits
back together but since all my
experience with the case of sharp V dull
has to do with kitchen knives it feels
like the doctor's worried about the
quality of his filet six days how was
Mark popping up off the table like a
doorbell just ringing his pizzas here he
just had a hole through his abdomen a
few days ago don't say he heals super
fast he's still got bruises on his face
so his stomach must still be healing
what's more interesting to me is why he
would do it so much of what's going on
here between Cecil and Nolan is bubbling
right under the surface we know these
two characters are hiding the most
secrets and they both are trying to game
each other that hostile Dynamic turns
this seemingly simple conversation into
a battle of wits and I'm living every
second of it start over treating a
relationship like a video game I'm just
trying to start over with Amber you know
I understand the goal but I do not
understand the method you want to show
her your serious by blocking your best
friend on a visit to a college you know
little to nothing about show highlights
the fact that it is constantly
overshadowing the butt if you can create
and disappear doors it will do you
really need to pack ever why not
manifest a new outfit each day from some
pine cones instead of lugging around all
the luggage a normal life a house a
husband kids I see your kids and raise
you in overprotective Parents Without
dated expectations when you need to fly
to another country you don't flap your
arms Flappy arm shaming dramatic much
I'm sorry I'm not you're being a jerk he
was being both dramatic and a jerk but
he was also making an argument
summarizing a conceptual framework for
addressing the limitations of human
longevity so instead of just calling him
an [ __ ] you could have responded with
a counter argument highlighting why you
think replacing hearts with carburetors
is a bad thing in the end this sin comes
down to Amber being addicted
constructive academic debate being this
captivated by a water fountain I'm
serious I think this is what I want Mark
says this after completing a series of
activities all in the quad I mean at
least go vet the cafeteria don't blame
me when you get to your first lunch and
realize the only choices are a
compressed chicken patty a melon-based
fruit cup and a giant milk machine that
likely never gets cleaned you know when
you start a sentence with I think you
automatically murder 90 of any romance
ants in it and when you over explain
Mark's crimes against passion you murder
the last 10 percent in this shot we see
Amber marker up close and personal with
what's left of funny Doug then in this
shot after they've taken a step back new
bystanders have found their way between
our guys and discount RoboCop meaning
that these two ran into Harm's Way just
so they could fall down running out of
Harm's Way save them if you want but
some people are already lost where the
hell did you go the tension created by
the whole Marx double life-causing
relationship problems feel so forced
while it's not entirely unbelievable it
is unbelievably frustrating you said you
wanted to start over oh this is
definitely getting a signal in the
middle of the [ __ ] Forest those are
normal levels for monster girl she has a
curse not a disease robot is still slow
dripping these medically necessary
details instead of just giving them a
full report and this doctor is still
treating Monster Girls injuries as if
she's a normal person why isn't Cecil
giving him the full report so I take it
we won when you have a character whose
only facial expression is an awkward
smile you're bound to have some strange
moments did the creators really think
Tom Hanks would be okay with these dead
eyes Nolan struck first is he analyzing
everyone else's costume to confirm this
this entire sequence of analyzing fabric
is fabricating facts for the sake of
sewing the plot together I feel gross
I'm taking a shower you feel gross so
you're taking a shower at the college
dorm to feel cleaner improper placement
of an exit sign you're better than ever
almost like before I lost my powers
maybe I should get my ass kicked more
often then rejoin the team at Guardians
HQ when your powers have mysteriously
miraculously and obviously returned but
the show doesn't want to talk about that
right now
going angle deep into sewer water to
save someone you [ __ ] one time behind
a Boathouse also why not call your buddy
before you descend into the stinky pits
of human waste or shoot a quick text
perhaps going low bro smells like butt
not the good kind well is anyone
concerned that the people at this party
are totally frozen in place is there
another bad guy lurking in the shadows
why is no one moved can't be lazy
animation it can't it's funny how
quickly things can fall apart
one day it seems like you have all the
time in the world and then the next it's
gone
For the Love of John Mayer Nolan just
say what you need to say show is really
playing hard to get to the bottom of
Nolan's subterfuge
I can't hear you I'll see you back at
Rick storm William is clearly terrified
and running for his life and Mark thinks
I'll see you back at Rick's dorm as an
appropriate response I know the power of
owners is strong with this one but the
show is straight up making it seem like
he's willing to let William die here
pole does not contain Glory waking up
after an emotional argument with your
eyewing still on fleek so in the
previous episode Nolan punched this wall
in a display of anger but does punching
a wall in Anger give you any kind of
emotional release when you can also
punch through asteroids this has to be
like you or eye punching through toilet
paper right here we see Adam Eve using
her powers to make coffee including
manually boiling the water look I still
don't fully understand what her powers
are and no I'm not going to research
them you nerd but can she not just
rearrange the atoms of the air itself to
create a steaming cup of morning go
juice instead of going through all these
steps why does she even need Go Juice
coffee brand coffee pork you need to
trust me she does not Debbie is
confronted Nolan with proof that he
murdered the Guardians so does he really
expect her to trust him that this was
all for the greater good just because
that's what obedient well-behaved wives
are supposed to do also the show shows
beginning to soap opera so hard that I'm
having flashbacks to my grandmother
yelling don't you dare
and while stress eating Werther's
Originals we'll talk later Nolan is
addicted
ceilings a floor and a roof hey hey Mark
it's Mom listen to me
people that do this with their voicemail
come on this is dumb yes diverting our
attention away from the main story to
give us more of this will they won't
they relationship B plot is dumb
this is why I'm always late or why I
don't show forget interrogation or torch
or the power of boners is apparently all
it takes for a superhero to reveal their
identity then why are we fighting we're
fighting because you lied to me you made
me feel stupid and unimportant it's a
secret identity mark would be
foreign
[Music]
premature being an ungrateful brat or
whatever the opposite of Celebration is
indoor fireworks if the flying pieces of
superheated plastic don't get you the
unannounced PTSD inducing explosion sure
will that's a guarantee we're the
Guardians of the globe baby if we can
die at any time uh we can drink it
anytime this logic's not exclusive to
the Guardians anything that's alive can
die at any time and anything that's
alive can drink at any time assuming it
has a mouth a digestive system and is of
legal age to drink iced tea now just
give the show a sin for acting like Rex
was capable of making a good point but
I'm lactose intolerant whoa hold on do
you know me at all I filled them with
beer I know Rex is all kinds of unhinged
but this beer situation must be
addressed I don't care how well he
cleaned these Gardens and we all know he
didn't there's still going to be an
unsettling amount of milk switching
around that beer why are you never this
industrious when it involves training
the manager at every job I've ever had I
mean except this one of course can I
refill your coffee Mr Simi I swear to he
had his head on the bench and he was
just standing over it prying it open
with a Phillips head screwdriver oh come
on no one's using a Phillips head
screwdriver to pry open a complex piece
of Machinery like robot's head you'd
obviously use a flathead for that
there I am alone and helpless despite
two-thirds of the Blue Man Group
acknowledging this is likely [ __ ]
they'll take baby Robo at his word which
results in them being swindled Gotta
Love villains who are exactly as dumb or
as smart as the plot needs them to be
sorry love and sinner listed in the TV
since thesauruses synonyms I'm a
terrible friend and a worse boyfriend
because quick do the thing
you're like a bad guy in a Samurai movie
who gets cut in half but thinks they're
fine until they're like oh my God my top
half sliding away from my bottom half
one cheeseburger was harmed in the
making of the simile also putting the
cheese on the bottom bun instead of the
top of the burger like a society hating
sociopath also also feeling about the
cheese and Bun half of your bifurcated
Burger instead of making sure you have
room for the heart attack in bun half
also also also what kind of monster goes
to the effort of setting out their
ketchup Burger and Fries only to leave
before eating a single bite of it aren't
there any Heroes left in this world
Velma Dinkley doesn't have a bigger part
in this episode
[Laughter]
there's that literal lorem ipsum text up
here on this monitor I don't know
whether it Addison for laziness or
remove a sin for ballsiness now I'm
lying I know exactly what to do there's
only one person I know who might be able
to go toe-to-toe with Omni man and come
out on top Debbie why would Cecil think
that Debbie is the best way to get to
Adam Eve wouldn't it be better to just
where's smart Debbie no [ __ ] you Robert
Kirkman continues his Crusade against
20th century innovators by using
Flathead screws to do the hard work
keeping Rudy's skull in place instead of
the far more useful cross head screws
invented by Mr Henry F Phillips this
procedure doesn't transfer you to the
new body it creates a copy of your mind
let's just file that under things Rudy
should definitely know already but thank
you for the clone's position of course
his brain's abnormal
you didn't think of that look at it a
couple of things here one they only just
found out this is what robot actually
looks like so how could he have planned
for that and two you are literally his
clone so why didn't you think of that
too his motor cortex is the size of a p
same for his occipital and parietal
lobes we've all been eaten alive by his
oversized cerebrum while writing this in
I learned that the cerebral cortex is
the outermost layer of the cerebrum and
houses the four major lobes frontal
parietal occipital and temporal so
either thing ones description of what's
happened to robot's brain is not quite
accurate or brain surgery is way more
complicated than I think it is and I
should probably put this scalpel down
compensating now which apparently is as
easy as twiddling two wires together I
mean this repair job would have been
less ridiculous if he'd attempted a
simple percussive adjustment the
laughable idea that a progress bar
wouldn't quickly go to 98 giving the
illusion that it's almost finished but
then take an hour to reach climax after
four or five attempts in at least one
reboot electricity screaming fire
excitement I'm sorry it wasn't you I I
think I understand the sentiment but
what a bizarre thing to be sorry about
in all the ways that matter he is him I
mean other than now occupying the body
of a younger version of a hero who he
didn't consult or receive consent from
before cloning but we've got the rest of
the season to explore there's only one
episode left and they're just pulling
this [ __ ] now and now that our deal is
complete it's time you both returned to
prison if Rudy intends on taking them
both to prison why did he bother handing
over the schematics to the caller of
course the answer is that the writers
needed the roided Smurfs to have the
collar so they can bring back the
immortal apparently the show is three
minutes short on run time and way under
spent on their animated blood budget
Rudy is a genius but apparently that
genius only extends to making slightly
bigger robots judging by Mark's choice
of dartboard placement a disregard for
human life must run in the family he's
not dead even after evacuating the
neighborhood we had to keep the yield
down
best it'll do is knock him on his ass
for an hour or two holy [ __ ] Cecil just
wasted a lot of people's lives
evacuating the neighborhood ahead of
time means he was always planning to
have Donald blow that place so what was
the point of sending the soldiers into
the house at all if he knew that even
this explosion wasn't going to do the
job what chance did they have texting
and flying so I'm helping you today
seeing all of this going on in the world
but deciding to help Mark with his girl
problems perhaps after all this time
poor aim is actually a clone thing not
just a stormtrooper thing
confusing cloning with telepathy I'd
argue even the slightest variation in
life experience would have an effect on
one's thoughts to the extent that the
longer each clone was alive the less
likely they'd be to be able to know what
the other is thinking but I'm not a
doctor so I'm gonna send this for being
a finishing each other sentences cliche
where's Mark William uh amber dumped him
and he didn't like my advice so he went
to go find Eve [ __ ] does he know
that and ended up being true but Mark
stormed off without mentioning a thing
about where he was going if you're gonna
be labeled a snitch at least be a
factually accurate snitch how do we know
know you're telling the truth ask me
something only robot would know despite
the Sound Logic of this idea they forego
any meaningful question and answer
segment making us all wonder why it was
even brought up in the first place
that is a much longer Story one that can
wait it's actually a very short story
while in the body of a robot 30 year old
Rudy developed feelings for a 24 year
old monster girl despite her being in
the body of a 10 year old he exploited
her attraction to Rex by cloning his
body and transferring his Consciousness
into it so that she'd fall in love with
him and they live a life of sciencing
[ __ ] together like I said it was short
not that it wasn't super [ __ ] creepy
can't you use your teleporter to bring
Mark and Eve back here you need to be
wearing one of these but it could have
rescued poor [ __ ] Donald right
breaking the fourth wall not even
omniman shall stop our sin Rays
[Laughter]
sorry but seriously why is omniman
making out like this laser beam is such
a big deal when he seems to have no
issues rickon starking his way through
it so he can blow up the source a
literal murder of crows 400 billion
dollars for the world's most expensive
nosebleed Tony Montana 1984. so you lied
to us about who you really were freed
the mahlers from prison stole Rex's DNA
conspired with criminals to grow
yourself a new body and you expect us
all to be like oh sure who wouldn't well
yeah when you say it like that it sounds
pretty ridiculous however let's not
forget that the person pointing out said
ridiculous situation was written by the
same person who created said ridiculous
situation to begin with the world was
fine before I came along it'll be fine
without my help better probably I'm sure
it's likely a deliberate juxtaposition
but the Marcus Moody and miserable about
being a teenage superhero B plot really
undercuts the fun of the catch omniman a
plot and now many minutes of omni man
being pummeled by Mindless robots who
can't possibly hurt him yes I'm both
asking to get back to the Omni Man
action and sending the Omni Man action
welcome to TV sins
further proof that every Universe needs
an Edna Mode this creature's impressive
but it can't even fly so here's a sin
for all the other possible routes
omniman could and should have taken to
get past it
that should buy us five minutes or so I
mean you could have easily doubled that
if you made your move as soon as the
zombie robot Soldier started attacking
instead of sitting back and enjoying the
show teleport me to invincible's
location cancer Hail Mary was so big she
burned off the teleport teleporters more
like Tela plotters am I right see
because they only work when the plot
needs them too I'll move on get to
Guardians HQ what Cecil listen to me and
do what I say or you could [ __ ] tell
her that omniman murdered everyone
instead of playing the situational
equivalent of the pronoun game with her
also why is using Adam even the new
Guardians to take down omniman the back
up to the back up to the backup plan
instead of being the actual plan if this
creature does take out omniman what the
[ __ ] do they call to take it out
yay a fight between a being we have no
reason to believe is even remotely
killable and another being who is
literally called The Immortal and who we
have already seen die horribly and
return to life who needs Stakes to keep
the audience invested when you have two
men punching each other really hard me I
do we need to talk we're all commercials
holy [ __ ] that actually worked this time
it feels
feels that Leon was cut together by
someone who's never watched the show we
have Debbie mad at omniman Omni man mad
at the house Cecil looking for Mark
Amber mad at Mark ooh Eve's here Rudy's
new body Cecil matted Omni man Debbie
looking for Mark The Immortal looking
for omniman and finishing with Mark
looking as confused as we are after that
barrage of Clips most of which are about
as orienting as a big Arrow saying you
are here on a slightly bloody button
otherwise blank sheet of paper The
Immortal survives this which I know is
rather redundant but I only highlight it
because he really should be called The
Humpty Dumpty as in he only seems to be
immortal after somebody bothers to put
him back together again Mark we need to
talk roll the previous episodes
commercials someone's controlling you
it's me Mark
just me believing someone that you think
is being mind controlled when they tell
you this it's time for you to know where
I really come from and roll this week's
commercials my goodness we're just a hop
skip and day would be Invincible at TV
sends away from a full deck and we
haven't even hit the title card yet I am
from viltrum but it's not the planet
I've told you about looks like today's
conductor on the exposition train will
be Nolan Grayson the next stop is the
planet philtrum we have created a
perfect civilization I'd say the
compulsory white leotards tell a
different story the perfect civilization
would have more than one fashion
designer in order for our people to
reach their full potential we had to
remove the weak from our society when an
advanced species know that physical
prowess is just one facet while
measuring the overall strength of a
society what about the architects who
dreamed the buildings into existence the
philosophers who Ponder the meaning of
life through their tails or the
scientists who holy [ __ ] did you see
that person get cut in half that was
awesome when it was over our population
was cut in half but what emerged From
the Ashes was Unstoppable since most of
the battling we see on screen looks like
a bunch of people taking cheap shots at
each other when they're not looking
seems like being weak just means you
don't have a spidey sense problem is we
have no idea how the so-called process
of random assassination would ever stop
wouldn't it keep going until there's
just one Highlander left we needed a
better more efficient way to conquer
worlds I mean robots right the
self-replicating ones that expand
exponentially would sure do the trick of
course that's going to be a lot harder
now that you've killed all the Nerds
isn't it our most trusted officers were
each given a planet to weaken by
themselves over the course of 20 [ __ ]
years even on his own I'm sure omniman
could have conquered Earth in six months
Max what's he been doing thinking maybe
understand if you spent that time
convincing Earth's governments that
vilter might rule was in their best
interest but it never even comes up 20
years of superheroing and father
figuring and for what we need to get
Earth ready to join the viltrum Empire
but why to paraphrase a certain captain
of the Enterprise what does God need
with a human viltermite DNA is so pure
you're nearly full-blooded is nearly
full-blooded really going to be enough
for a species that Thanos half of its
actually full-blooded population for
being too weak but we can help them we
can stop Wars eliminate hunger omniman's
burden I do love your mother but she's
more like a a pet to me shows dropped
enough hints that Nolan and Debbie doing
the horizontal Mambo the biggest being
Mark that I'm now hoping Nolan just
never learned the proper use of the word
pet what do you think is gonna happen
then I'm gonna go enslave my friends for
a bunch of aliens I've never met built
for my kids being able to give this much
side eye without ever turning your head
I truly hope Mark lives up to his name
he's gonna say it isn't he to face his
father and survive it's not a build up
on this one huh he'll need to be
wait what what is this okay that's just
me having a bit of fun I mean if you're
gonna be that predictable you really
leave me no choice but to make my own
fun everyone in this group apparently
attended classes at the Chicago Campus
of the Rick on Stark School of running
away from things calculating the
relative weights of Abraham Lincoln's
head and asteroid flying through space
in this falling building is an amount of
math that is very much above my pay
grade that being said this show is doing
an insufficient job of helping us
understand how heavy anything is for
these powered individuals so even though
this building may actually be heavy for
invincible we have no way to tell if
that makes sense or is just what the
story needed at the moment ironically we
missed this in a previous episode but as
one of our great communicators once said
fool me once shame on shame on you fool
me a full man Can't Get Fooled Again so
the sin is always is a Niles assists
that was your fault your stubbornness
against the inevitable killed those
people confusing stubbornness with
Newton's loss of motion
I suppose we're meant to believe Cecil's
getting this footage from the little
flying ball things they introduced
earlier so here's a sin for convenient
footage provided by convenient Tech
which Nolan is conveniently not
destroying maybe this time you'll learn
we can't show much more of the scene so
instead enjoy these royalty-free
pictures of puppies while I remove a sin
for the sheer brutality of this train
sequence this is exactly the sort of an
actual super villain would pull to
demonstrate to Mark how fragile humanity
is and how they're powerless to resist
vultramite Supremacy
no all puppies I see you almost die to
protect them maybe you were a vulture
mate when you came to Earth but you've
changed saying this to your father after
he just used your face as a weapon of
mass destruction I don't know if this is
a viltromite quirk but I feel like
Mark's suit shouldn't be moving
independently of the blood that's
covering it omni-man is like breaking
the sound barrier right now or some [ __ ]
so again where is this footage coming
from if Cecil brought Joseph Kaczynski
into direct we have a right to know Omni
man is a dick to this boat
twice I can always start again make
another kid nothing in the season has
really answered the question of why
Nolan had a kid in the first place or
why he did such a bad job of
indoctrinating Mark into his whole
Master species belief system I mean not
that I wanted that but we all know you
have to start such things pretty early
right if I have to watch this game I'd
have a better View from Above believing
the only thing preventing baseball from
being watchable is Altitude this is a
way a waste of everyone's time there's
so much more I could be doing right now
oh yeah but it comes with my Amazon
Prime subscription which is worth it for
the two-day shipping alone and this show
is by no means the worst oh we're still
on baseball aren't we when he feels joy
we feel Joy we interrupt this flashback
which interrupted a truly epic superhero
ass beating to bring you Debbie
explaining the unshakable bond between
parent and child and as sweet as that is
it ends up making the scene entirely
safe Mark plays stickball really well
and everyone cheers and that is a lie
who cheers for someone else's kid in
fact there are only five other people
here in the bleachers and if the teams
are even the four blue shirted kids here
mean there should be at least eight kids
total now unless none of the blue
shirted kids have parents love them
enough to put up with baseball why is
everyone cheering for team red Mark's
blood not being Invincible I can't begin
to explain the devastation all the
important people just so happen to be
tuned into the same news position
Channel at this exact time Joe continues
to give us updates on the whereabouts
and goings-on of the Mahler Twins win at
this point we don't care and if we're
honest did we ever this hatim book The
Guardians of the globe and Adam Eve are
on the scene okay the Guardians mean
well but rescue operations like this are
incredibly complicated I doubt duplicate
has a clue how to safely remove this
child from these iron bars and don't
even get me started on Rex blow
literally blowing up Rubble to find
survivors to keep your remarks safe
Nolan Grayson officially died when the
house across the street exploded sure
well look at all suspicious is that
Nolan Grayson who looks identical to
omniman died on the same day that
omniman went on a rampage and also
disappeared at least Clark Kent had
[ __ ] glasses in a different hairstyle
and don't be alarmed if you see yourself
in mark on the news we send proxies to
the funeral they've already had the
[ __ ] funeral without even telling
Debbie Nolan is dead and the media were
there holy [ __ ] won't Debbie's friends
and family think it a bit odd that they
weren't invited no one was doing
everything under my nose and I never saw
it
I wouldn't be able to live with myself
if I didn't make things as right as they
can be oh my that wasn't a jab right
into Debbie's heart this devious prick
just angered me so much that I was
compelled to give this a sin but then I
realized I felt that way because his
character was written and performed so
well that he made me feel a feeling
which compelled me to remove a sin but
then I realized that making me feel
anything against my own will is an
automatic ads oh also saying Nolan was
doing everything under my nose would be
overselling in a bit I mean he did Kill
The Guardians of the globe but aside
from that all we have evidence of him
doing is raising a family writing travel
books and saving the world occasionally
I said stop
just a reminder that monster girl can
only do this a certain amount of times
before she Benjamin buttons herself into
Oblivion was posing for the discount
Avengers Glory shot really worth that we
get it they're a team now Moody Montage
of Life returning to normal set against
an equally Moody Indie song cliche the
animators who obviously took advantage
of a sale at the generic green backpack
store the angle on the shot is weird it
makes it look like Debbie is sleeping
standing up against the wall but the
real issue is that with all the [ __ ]
technology at his disposal Cecil still
couldn't get her a bed wait a minute
but fortunately for everyone involved
these slip-ups tend to only happen when
both parties are already aware of the
secret and the plot just needs them to
both get on the same page as quickly as
possible you've been drifting out for
almost two weeks but my guys got you
patched up good taking credit for
someone else's power of invincibility
invincibut the water America drinks so
conveniently from their Taps is laced
with a chemical that inhibits the
ability to see certain frequencies of
light using your show to invent insane
conspiracy theories is all fun and games
until someone attempts to cure
themselves with magic rocks invest their
life savings in a psychic stock broker
or Awards an oscared army of the Dead
there's enough actual Madness in the
world without having my animated shows
add to it thank you you and everyone
else in America do not have the ability
to see the things in this room
you'd be surprised how often we use this
I swear the show is making this
description just vague enough to make me
look like a dick for questioning it but
the show forgets that I have zero issues
looking like a dick so here we go let's
assume that the chemical in question has
been invented without a single
whistleblower coming forward about this
tampering with the water table how does
this work in the real world okay this
room is flooded with that light but how
do you use it outside of this room
without it looking like a sudden white
void of nothingness has suddenly
appeared we monitored your father until
he left our solar system he didn't
change trajectory so he's going
somewhere pretty damn far away nor he
waited until he knew he was out of range
and then changed Direction basically
Cecil you don't have a [ __ ] clue so
don't you stand there and expect me to
take your retina altering dihydrogen
monoxide quietly guess who's finally
getting his power previously
uninvincible again you know how many man
is mine said your dad was killed when a
gas line blew up across the street not
that hard to figure it out from there
right what did I just say oh man it's so
good to see you're all right I mean
after everything on the TV about you and
Omni William [ __ ] this up again and
again it doesn't matter because the
person who he thinks doesn't know the
secret and really shouldn't know the
secret knows the secret someone's flying
towards Earth from deep space we're
still trying to figure out who it is but
writers thinking we would fall for this
Omni man returning to earth fake out
with less than 10 minutes left in the
episode you know about Mark and omniman
now so you might as well know
why what kind of logic is that this is
like Cecil saying well you know about
the invisa potions we've all been
pumping into your faucet so you may as
well know about the aliens that killed
Kennedy or the AI from the future that
now runs the planet after manipulating
the internet into creating the Snyder
cut just as a demonstration of its power
the sounds of it I'm the one who should
be apologizing if I check my orders
properly I would have seen that Earth
was flagged for vulture might take over
yes but that would have been mighty
inconvenient for a series that depends
on keeping its main character in the
dark until the finale much better to
make you exactly as incompetent as the
plot requires until it doesn't anymore
can't imagine what you're going through
literally never even met my father
I'm sitting this season for not having
more Seth Rogen I mean Alan the alien
what's the plan in the meantime how do
you say next season on Invincible
without saying next season on invincible
you think you could do these things but
you can't Nemo you're not even gonna be
here are you not even supposed to be
here today it starts with one of you
then principal Wiggins barfed on a
lumberjack that was sitting next to him
mayor Grundy barfed on his wife's tits
this is going to be a little awkward
for both of us you see there's a certain
thing that happens between normal
healthy people it's called chemistry
it's kind of like peeing your pants on
purpose
what if peeing your pants is cool
consider me Miles Davis
hit me what hey Joey did I not tell you
just to do it and I'm telling you gotta
do it
Joey I'm telling you something I know
what you said I ain't doing it who the
hell are you I'm uh I'm Batman okay
you're an animal yes there we go you're
a tiger you're tuning the target you're
great duck wing
[Music]
Janet's made a lot of talk talk into my
ear Holes about you Michael Michael
clickle clayco that's a meatball boy
[Music]
freeze guys we get it it's a code red
enough oh hey it's the Iceman I'm just
trying to figure out what are your
powers again
just connected man but that's what
happens when people get into air battles
robot I have a name
it's Dennis Dennis McCoy hello
you're terrified of me aren't you I am
not scared how's it going in here I
brought snacks so many snacks
snacks holy conflagration wow that guy
is toast this chick is toast
[Music]
for the last time
join me
bye
don't you dare shush me just know I have
a whole bag of shh with your name on it
that was the best night of my life I'm
about to eat nachos it's the greatest
moment of my life calculating Landing
ellipse based on our last uncorrupted
navstate I'd say we're somewhere in this
60 by 120 kilometer ellipse we just got
to close another downrange variables
it's about the math this is it that
moment they told us about in high school
where one day algebra would save our
lives don't open that it's an alien
planet is there air you don't know what
is your purpose here nobody exists on
purpose nobody belongs anywhere
everybody's gonna die
I'm Harry we're with you guess what
Donald found when we searched your
office
tiny pies say
have such sights to show you
Hansel so hot right now
surprise [ __ ] you look good guy
you can't handle the truth what was the
name of that place in Bordeaux the one
with the chocolate pastry thingies how
can you think of food at a time like
this who's your boss
Machine Head on with the trash company
it to Ferry drugs to stash houses all
over the city beautiful super awesome
sexy stash cows the only place we're
guaranteed to find Machine Head is 60
stories up inside this building there is
a level where no elevator can go
and no stair can reach
[Music]
you're doing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this battle is beneath me
not quite my temple yeah I mean it
sounds about like Bonk that's about it
right there's not much more to it in it
I'll fix you we have the technology hey
let me up [ __ ] if this is some joke
or some weird sex I'm not in the mood
you're going to be beautiful you're
going to be
I don't get a BP start two large bore
IVs sailing Wide Open Cross for 10 units
give me four units of O Negative down
there stat dropping NG tube and get Dr
Benton in here there's no place for a
pediatrician mark
mark
mom
oh hi Mark and no sex
no sex are you insane
at school or college your mom goes to
college you can't save the world
Samantha you think you could do these
things but you just can't Nemo how does
a machine have emotions by subjecting
myself to erotic imagery
it's cold out there every day I finally
rest
and watch the sun rise on a grateful
Universe were you were you blackmailed
did they threaten me or Mark
no
then why
you need to trust me like Sans Through
The Hourglass so are the days of our
lives
come with me if you want to live no
never
can't where's Mark Debbie where's
waldoes
[Music]
where's Waldo
hello okay you Chief that's weird Auto
Parts transform and roll out
I know it's kind of like we almost
finish each other's sentences if you
deliberately sabotage my band I will
[ __ ] you like a pig
now are you a rusher or are you a
dragger that is a much longer Story one
that can wait until whatever crisis this
is has been resolved by all means Dr
Selden speak
it's over nine thousand
have you ever smoking any pot today
how high are you thumbs up their asses
thumbs up their asses do you have any
idea how much I make a year I mean even
if I told you you wouldn't believe it
[Music]
this isn't flying this is falling with
style look what they need to mimic a
fraction of our power danger zone
it was at this moment that he knew he
[ __ ] up I exist
only to protect Krypton that is the sole
purpose for which I was born
oh my that is a No-No did you see that
did you see oh that was amazing
I've seen better swings on a playground
wait a minute where are we you are no
longer part of the system you are above
the system over it Beyond it where them
where they we are the Men in Black